the Marvel Cinematic Universe you might
have heard of it over the last decade or
so over the course of three phases we've
had fourteen movies grossing a total of
over ten billion dollars making the MCU
V highest-grossing franchise in the
world oh and let's not forget that there
are eight more movie still to come god I
love stats naturally over the course
that time we've got to know the likes of
Iron Man Captain America Thor and Hulk
pretty well both to be more specific
Robert Downey jr. Chris's Evans and
Hemsworth and well edward norton or Mark
Ruffalo depending on what decade is it's
hard not to see these actors donning the
spandex nowadays but that casting lineup
could have been so very different and
i'm not talking about Tom's monstrous
like a remake right anyway we've Doctor
Strange set to shake things up we take a
look back at six castings that would
have completely changed the marvel
cinematic universe as we know it
improbably my favorite MCU what if John
Krasinski almost played Captain America
yes the world's greatest paper salesman
office prankster and Pam lover Jim from
the US office could have been the first
avenger as he revealed to Conan O'Brien
he got all the way to a costumed
audition and as he was halfway through
squeezing into cap spandex he saw
something that made him withdraw from
the role and all of a sudden Chris
Hemsworth walked by his door and he's
like by night knowing I'm good this is
stupid decisive Jim don't put yourself
down as a woman who's seen 13 hours
believe me you could have lost that wall
my goodness to be honest though the US
Army would have never admitted him with
this haircut or stood for any of his
tomfoolery but imagine if he did bring
some of Jim's ways to the MCU every time
Tony Stark does something that irks him
he does a classic look to the camera
maybe he could dress up like Loki to
drive him nuts all the classic set the
tesseract in a bowl full of jelly
oh you know it was me
now we all know tom hiddleston sorry
it'll stun for his role as trickster god
Loki but he doesn't actually originally
auditioned for the part of Thor himself
even going as far as to pack the muscle
on and Don this horrific blonde wig yeah
it's not hard to see why they went with
this instead according to director
kenneth branagh he did a tremendous job
but just wasn't thought but while
hiddleston wasn't right for thor his
troublesome demeanor did land him a spot
on the table Asgard as Loki luckily for
both hiddleston and Marvel fans
everywhere his first major motion
picture quickly propelled him forward
that's not only the great low key but
the single best Marvel villain in the
MCU which let's be fair isn't too hard
and to be fair his vision of Thor is
still world better than tams
over the Marvel almost on this list
Joaquin Phoenix as Bruce Banner was the
farthest away from being a reality in
fact he was only ever rumored to be tied
to the role and that was at a time when
Marvel wanted Edward Norton to reprise
his role from 2008's The Incredible Hulk
so why would he have changed the MCU
well the answer to that depends on which
what he fina qui would have got on the
one hand we could have got the Golden
Globe and Academy award-winning Joaquin
Phoenix that Joaquin Phoenix would
probably have given us a tortured Bruce
Banner unlike any we've seen before on
the other we could have had the awkward
but endearing qualities of Theodore
Twombly from her offset by a tortured
Bruce Banner grappling with the gamma
born beast within him or we could have
had the other Joaquin Phoenix you know
the confusing experiment or performance
artist that decided to make a
mockumentary about his real life
transition into a fake career in rap
during his performance on his face
Joaquin rockin out of control beard and
gave incoherent stage interviews as
someone who prefers to do unconventional
projects and add a little flair to his
performances who knows what kind of
havoc he could have wreaked in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe then there's
the fourth Joaquin Phoenix this guy
we who
well viewers
truth is while Sam Rockwell appeared as
arms dealer Justin Hammer in iron man 2
he was actually on director Jon Favreau
shortlist to play the man of iron
himself Favreau reveal that Rockwell was
only act as he was looking at for Tony
Stark early on in the casting process
albeit as a dark horse alternative of
course it's now unimaginable to think of
anyone else but Robert Downey jr. as I
man but Rockwell would have made for a
very different take on the character
although if you look at his performance
in the movie moon he doesn't really have
the best track record when it comes to
artificial intelligence so hang around
the Jarvis probably when I've gone to
her and one of the last time she was
fighting an evil superpower he was doing
so as a guinea pig from the movie
g-force James Barr never had these
problems so while Sam Rockwell is a
great actor maybe it's for the best that
we keep our current Tony Stark in his
red and gold armor although he did get
to hang out with mickey rourke in a cool
bird first we good aberg oh yeah things
are gonna get easier ooh child things
will get brighter bring it down heart
there have been more actors title role
of star-lord than infinity thumbs and by
that we mean more than six because
there's only six Infinity stones
guardians of the galaxy was a risky
project for Marvel it followed the
ragtag bunch of intergalactic heroes
that only diehard comic book fans really
knew anything about and with a squad
that included a green alien assassin a
gun crazy raccoon a talking tree and a
pile of humorless muscles Marvel needed
someone anyone that the audience could
relate to the first our Lord the only
human on the squad Marvel needed a
bankable leading man the studio cast a
wide net to find him and it dragged in a
whole bunch of potentials there was the
hapless drug dealer uncle Owen Stephen
Hawking Dean Winchester this dick head
elf the no bed from the OC the pushover
the totally isn't good enough for
Veronica Mars the worst Scott Summers
ever Lex Luthor hello my legal name is
Robin actually and the career of the
Dennis system the guy Marvel eventually
settled on as we all now know was Chris
Pratt the chubby idiot from Parks and
Rec thankfully he was perfect and
Guardians transformed him from a comedy
schlub to a global superstar that would
go on to Rayce dinosaurs all those
actors that audition could probably have
been decent but it's hard to imagine
they would have had the kind of
chemistry that Pratt and Batista head ok
and I got you back big boy ok I got you
back I won't touch you again that's the
last time I touch it
while John Krasinski almost picked up
the vibranium shield to become captain
america his lovely wife Emily Blunt was
almost like Widow in 2009 she was an
up-and-coming star thanks to
scene-stealing roles in the devil wears
prada and dan in real life and she was
in talks with Marvel to play Natasha
Romanov in Iron Man to those talks
peated off due to scheduling conflicts
but after the success of iron man what
film could possibly be bigger or more
exciting than its follow-up Gulliver's
Travels po boy it's actually not blunts
fault after signing her devil wears
prada contract she was obliged to appear
in a movie of 20th Century Fox's
choosing sadly for blunt that movie was
the jack black fronted Gulliver's
Travels all might not have been lost for
Emily and the MCU as for a while she was
frontrunner to play Captain Marvel
before the role went to the
oscar-winning brie Larson but it seems
like once not phased with skipping out
on the MCU as her career has gone from
strength to strength with lead turns in
the girl on the train sicario looper and
of course shaming everyone's yoga skills
in edge of tomorrow
so they were our alternative Avengers
but let us know which of them you think
would have made for good Marvel heroes
and for more videos like this one make
sure to LIKE and subscribe to gamespot
we'll see you next time